you're watching the Valley's most
accurate forecast on 8 News Now
well we're finally really starting to
see the clouds gather over the mountains
and they've been pretty high up but now
they're starting to get lower winter
weather advisory is in place now for the
spring mountains until tomorrow morning
at 10 A.M look at the temperatures where
they started this morning for the valley
it was cold down in the 30s even below
freezing down there St Rose Parkway and
31 in Southern Highlands and Mountains
Edge at freezing too 20's up at Kyle
Canyon now we're developing some breezes
as we get those temperatures back up to
at least in the low 50s now at noon
especially between Pahrump and Las Vegas
we're getting some southerly winds but
also in areas Northwest of the valley up
around Tonopah still chilly at 28 at the
noon hour but we've been getting some
Gusty winds kingman's also had some wind
46 degrees the South Winds will develop
first and then very chilly Northerly
winds will set up tonight as the system
really pushes through quickly so there
is a chance of late day rain into the
evening and overnight and cold enough
air that we could see a little snow
mixing all the way down to 3000 feet so
some Valley neighborhoods may have a mix
of some rain and snowflakes but we don't
expect anything to really stick some
other areas might see it but not here in
the valley Gusty chilly North winds
tonight and into tomorrow and then just
cool days and cold cold mornings into
early next week so by six o'clock we'll
see some light showers around but once
we get into the later evening and later
night hours as you look and see some
areas of white that's where we're
starting to see maybe the possibility of
some snow mixing with the rain even into
the overnight hours we might still see
that up along U.S 95 Southern Clark
County but especially into Mohave County
and up into Lincoln County this is cold
air coming in from a system dropping out
of Canada and into the Great Basin and
we've been seeing some good snow in
Northern Nevada up into Utah it's
starting to thin out a little bit
there's just not a lot of moisture with
it so we'll see what we get it is only
about a 30 percent chance of some rain
showers but really the snow I think is
kind of the most exciting part and as I
said winter weather advisories already
in place now for our local mountains up
into Lincoln County as well as Utah and
Arizona and then we've also got winter
we've got wind advisories for areas west
of Las Vegas where we expect the
stronger winds to develop so look for
highs in the low 50s a chance of late
day and evening showers and those
showers could last until about midnight
off and on they're kind of scattered and
again maybe a little snow mixed with the
rain those North winds tonight and
through Friday that's going to make it
feel extra cool so get those warm
jackets keep them with you and then
through the weekend nice Sunshine but
again staying below normal highs in the
low 50s mornings around freezing John
get ready for the briskness thank you
Sherry